hey what's up my name's samuel lee's
every single wednesday i interview
somebody on my youtube channel
that's been through my training and has
become financially free
two years ago i interviewed a guy called
raheem now raheem came into this country
with nothing 15 years old
he was an orphan he was put through
foster care and he built up his own
property portfolio
after attending my training and now two
years later
he's killing it this guy's honestly he's
got his own property shop we're in
cardiff
bar properties he's got loads of rent to
rent properties
lease option agreements he's investing
heavily into cardiff let's have a chat
see what he's up to you're going to love
this one let's go
hey um raheem bar so good to see you
really nice to have you in my office as
well i really appreciate it you know
taking the time driving from all the way
from london yeah absolutely
down there is my first time at your
offices so for anyone that doesn't know
who you are
yeah why don't you give a little bit of
background because you're doing
absolutely amazing things in
property you've got your own shop we've
just been around a whole bunch of your
houses yeah
we've known each other now for a few
years yeah um give me the back story
because
i mean right from the very beginning
because your story is phenomenal
this is not your first time on my
youtube channel this is your second time
absolutely it's been about two years
yes so this is catch up but give me the
lowdown for anyone to know who you are
wow basically um
where do i start i moved i moved i
migrated to this country at the age of
15. i'm obviously
dumped in the city somewhere i was able
i was being i was then picked up by
the local authorities then moved into a
foster home
um obviously it was difficult when i
moved there english wasn't my first
language i had to learn the language
and london was really really tough then
so many crime going on
but i was i was lucky enough to have a
foster mom who actually guided me
through the process so
she was able to advise me to guide me i
was able to go to college and
university because my dream job was to
become an accountant i was able to
achieve that
only to realize that it wasn't really my
dream job because my manager was so
stressed out
and she didn't have time to do anything
then i decided probably probably maybe
the
thing i want to get into so i started
doing research lots of research every
day binge studies about properties then
i picked up i i saw a video about you
and then obviously i saw the book buy
low rent how it was that's the one so i
read that book then i said i cannot wait
to meet you then obviously i went to
your crash course which was
absolutely amazing lots of people were
there the energy
and i really like connected with you for
a few reasons because the charity works
you do that actually draws me to you
as well as the stage performance the way
you actually encourage and motivates
people to actually get to
what do what they want to do so that
inspired me a lot straight after the
crash course i went on
basically executing all the strategies i
learned on that course that day so that
then
enables me to get i think five to six
properties within a month
so that that really really helps me and
then obviously when i went to dfe
that also expediates my own my whole
process and i was able to come back
and implement exactly what you thought
in the course so i really really
appreciate that basically because i've
learned a lot from that
and i still use those strategies and
skills i've learned from there
to actually even get my own estate
agency so yeah thank you thanks very
much for that a respect
so those first five or six houses then
you got after the property investors
crash course
what kind of houses were there because
you didn't have money did you yeah
i i i i didn't have money so what i did
was i had a partner then which
i now know is a jv partner so we started
from one property
that was before i joined the course and
then he knew what i was doing then
because after the course i thought i've
done discussion i knew everything about
proper time experience i got the skills
and then he goes like okay if you can
get the proper second invest then that's
how we build the portfolio then
and then i start doing and once i've
started getting cash flows from those
people i started doing it myself so and
then
and then i had to go in myself now start
doing this that's how i got
all the deals so what i do also i tend
to negotiate well with the landlords
some of them i don't pay rent for a few
months so i use the money i get from the
tenants
that already moved in to pay the
landlord yes so
um so yeah that's how i was able to um
raise the cash flow to do some of the
deals
that's incredible and you know what the
thing that you've got going for you more
than
anyone i've ever met is you just
implement immediately so as soon as you
learn something
yeah was how many days after the crash
course was it when you secured your your
rent to render
well i think it was within 24 hours
you know because what i did was when i
came back i did not sleep i was
literally searching for deals
as soon as i wake up in the morning book
all the viewings and i went and viewed
these properties
yeah right and then obviously when i
went there i used the energy
that i see you i go there with
excitement happiness and then
in my head the deal is already done
right i see the journey in my mind's eye
before i actually execute the deal yeah
so obviously i went there then that's
what it is now that rent to rent deal
that you got just after the crash course
um it wasn't actually the best
deal in the world was it yeah it wasn't
um because i was so excited um from the
course saying i can do this plus what
i've already
um done from my previous deal so i did
not negotiate on that deal so much that
so i can make profit on it
but um it was a mistake so obviously
because i've agreed to the landlord i
decided to actually stick to it because
i've given my word my word is my bond so
i took the deal it wasn't a good deal
but now when we had this opportunity
with kovid
i said probably i may not be able to
subsidize that property anymore i handed
it back to the
to the landlord and the landlord was
happy to so you get it you use
covid as a bit of an opportunity to
really release yourself from
exactly so yeah i was able to explain to
the landlord as there why i'm doing it
and i have a few pro i've got a few
properties for him as well so you
totally understand where my point of
view
and the agreement also we had was um he
knew i wasn't making profit out of the
deal because i told him i tell him
exactly what i do
and i said however if you can refer me
with to other landlords i will use some
of those profits to actually subsidize
that property
so we're able to do that obviously
because of covid19 we get impacted
slightly due to something and not paying
or moving out
so i wasn't being able to actually use
all my cash flows to subsidize that
property
hence the reason why i decided to take
this opportunity to actually hand it
back in place
but that landlord although that property
wasn't great
yeah you got some other properties from
the landlord
correct i had all the other properties
are amazing deals because
um i negotiated a lot more on those
deals the funny thing was
the property next door i got it almost
60 below the one next door only because
i saw the kitchen then i fully love in
the
kitchen i went with my heart instead of
my head so i
disclosed that deal and when i went back
and looked at the figure i realized it
was the wrong deal but
because i've got over some of these
properties so um it really helped me
able to hold the property that that long
until this time when
i handed it back yeah i mean what would
you say to somebody because i think
you're living proof
yeah you know you came into this country
with nothing you went through
foster foster care yeah i mean you
really
really were starting with nothing and a
lot of people in that situation
would have gone on to do nothing with
their life yeah but you didn't do that
you went to university
you trained to be an accountant that's
pretty that's that's impressive that
would be a story in and of itself
but then you then didn't want to have a
job you wanted to become financially
independent
you got trained you paid for training of
course you did the deal finally
extravaganza
you you um got lots of deals you've now
worked yourself up to the point where
you've got
a lot of properties and i know you don't
necessarily like to um
brag yeah of course yeah you don't like
to brag no why is that
um because i think um it's not about
what you have
it's about how many people you've
impacted positively and again i've
learned that from you
i believe in adding value in whatever i
do in life if i'm not adding value
there's no point
me doing it so i rather talk about the
value i've added
to the landlords i work with as well as
the tenants i've helped
occupy these houses one of my joyous
moments is when i see a tenant moved
into a house
i know that i've added value not just
added value i've provided them a home
yeah a place that they could hold call
home that's why
until today when most of my tenants are
moving in i tend to go with them
because that's that's the pleasure of
pleasure i get from it so that's that's
the reason why i like to do that
that's the reason why i want to add
value to see people achieving what they
want to achieve or get what they wanted
to do
and hence the reason why i'm into
property so i really really love it
i see it as a hobby some people think
i'm crazy my wife think i'm crazy
saying oh why do it's always about
properties you watch tvs properties you
listen to the news
to do with properties um podcast is to
do with properties even your music has
to do with business stuff right
she's like i don't know what sort of
world i'm living in but i think i just i
just like it you know i love it and i
think
um learning from yourself again is the
energy and education you have you're
always learning and you're always
progressing so i'm taking that from that
because when i moved into the uk
at a very young age it was difficult you
know especially when you live in london
um one you're living in a foster home
two you're surrounded by negativity
right
and there are lots of crimes you know
i was able to extract myself from that
it was really really difficult because i
had to move away
and that really hurts me because
people think i have left them and then
ignored them
i don't really want to live with them
but in back of my head i said the only
way i can progress is to separate myself
from the people who are not thinking the
way i think because the people i
surround myself with was
when is the next party when is the
football game on is on where we want to
go on holidays
and they're not thinking about what can
i do to add value what can i do to make
myself better
for my kids or for my family so it was
difficult some of my friends went to
prison
some of them involved in lots of stuff
that they could not get
that they should not have got involved
in but um and again with the
with the guidance and my perseverance of
wanting to do something better with my
life
i was able to lose very close friends of
mine
as a result of me moving away because
i always know back in my head they may
not like me now
but after three four five years when i
come back they will see me sort of
like a hero or something like that and
that's happening now so when i go to
london everybody wants to see me now
right back on the days nobody want
everybody hated me but when i go
when it's running back let's have a chat
with him let's see what he's doing or
something
so um it was difficult but i was able to
separate myself one thing i've learned
also from you and from others of people
if you want to be successful
you have to separate yourself with the
people that are not thinking the way you
think
yeah surround yourself with like-minded
individuals
people that are doing better than you
did so you can learn from me for example
you will be a close friend to me now
because i would love to learn from you
consistently throughout that way i can
grow expand and learn and bounce ideas
from you so
that was the most difficult decisions
i've ever made to be able to separate
myself
but looking up looking back it has
really helped me really helped me now
surround myself like people like
yourself
people are doing any sort of business
and business stuff that i'm doing
and i'm able to contribute now i can
give back to charity
i can go to where i want to get i can
literally
dictate my um my my um way of life
and the other reason why i went to
property stuff also is because
my dream job was to be an accountant as
i've already told you earlier on
but i soon realized it wasn't the job
for me because
so many politics kissing asses
and you would have to be
um answering to people i hated taking
instructions
and i realized that the only way i may
be able to succeed looking at my manager
she's been traveling countries to
countries every single day
she's stressed out don't have time for
family and
she's always on the go i looked at
myself i said i don't want to live this
life in the next 10 years
right i want to make make sure i do
something better with my life then
i start thinking about what can i do to
actually get myself out of this rat race
then i started looking for all the stuff
i've just told you about but what i did
also was
which which i think helped me a lot was
is to which was one of the hardest
decision as well is to quit my job
right um just got married got my wife
in the country because my wife was born
in africa as well got her here
she arrived three months later got
pregnant i don't know as soon as you
arrived basically
living in a shared house and uh decided
to quit my job at the same time people
thought i was crazy
you've got a wife doesn't know how to
speak english baby along the way you
live in a shared house and you quit in
your job
right but i'm happy that my wife was
backing me up on that she said listen i
don't i don't care where we live as long
as you're pursuing your dream
go for it right so i told my manager i
wanted to quit everybody thought i was
crazy from 35 000 pounds to zero pound a
month
right quit the job it went really hard
it went really really really tough
and uh baby came along um baby cry in a
shared house as you may know tenants one
movie now because that house was my
house took in a rental rent as well
right
so but we're not happy about it so i had
to move
i thought i've got two two rental sa now
i can live on it not realizing if you've
got a wife and a baby
it's a completely different story right
very expensive people to
look after so and then obviously it went
hard and really really tough
and i took a laptop wanting to apply for
job
i said no i'm not going back i've burned
that boat
i need to survive in that island right
it was really difficult
but i had to survive you know how to
survive in that island so
um what i did was also i made sure i had
so many problem at work before i left
customer manager cause the supervisor
said i'm not coming back ever again
right
to make sure that i'm not gonna even
think about going back
right so when it went really really
tough right i'm thinking oh i shouldn't
have said that but
but i said to myself listen you know
i'll have to get it done
you know survive in that island bundy
boat survive and that's how i got
survived and
by then i've already bought a property
wrong location
wrong price um everything was wrong in
that property basically so
i was the labor in that property so um
he's in portal but
south wales my first ever property so i
bought it for 50k i thought wow that's a
good deal
everything was amazing and did the work
i was a laborer for the builders
done the works valuation came back i
spent about 25k to do it
up violation came back it's about 60k
right i was literally shocked you know
it's in a village there are only like 50
people that lives in the village
right massive house but it's it's no
good
so um then what i've learned from that
also
is you pay for your mistake
you pay for your success in two ways
you've got you've got
um entry you either pay for your
mistakes
or pay for the course or pay to educate
yourself yeah so what i've done was i
learned from that i paid it two twice
basically i put my success
um thing twice one for my mistake cost
me 25 000 pounds
plus i had to pay for courses to
actually get it done
and i realized that it's not going to
work so
that's the reason that's one of the
reason why i always like to educate
myself
i don't pretend like i know everything
even someone walked into my office
as long as they know something i'm happy
to learn yeah that's
that's really really inspiring and as
well over the last two years
i mean you've really i think when when
you came on my youtube channel last time
you might have been you had it you had
maybe four or five rent events from
memory you were making a few thousand
pound a month yeah you just quit your
job everything was great
now i mean i've met your staff yeah
and you've changed their lives yeah and
and i mean i was just with
larry and he was saying that he was
living in a car
yeah homeless yeah and you and you found
him
and and and now he's working for you
he's doing deals every day and you've
changed his life yeah so he's literally
found me for some reason i don't know
what happened
i was in my office um he was dr
he drove past he said he saw me in the
office yeah so then he went round
got lost but he eventually got to me
came to explain his situation i said no
i know where i could leave this guy
and go without support i said listen i
don't have money to pay for your
accommodation but i can try the best way
possible to help you
what can i do to help you what sort of
skills do you have that you could take
advantage of
and you told me what i used to do i said
okay you know why not take a desk in my
office
i've got a funnel of deals coming
through my office you try to
qualify them negotiate the deals i can
close the deals
and whatever deals we sell you you get
commissioner out of it a couple of weeks
later he said oh he doesn't want to live
in the cash like what do you want to go
into one of my
one of my rent to rent properties he
said yes ask him to pick whatever house
you want to go into
move in there so he's one of my houses
now obviously now he's doing really well
he's closing lots of deals
and yeah he's destined to do great
things and he
is you wouldn't know that meaning he's
sharp he's not polished
yeah you don't know absolutely thanks
you wouldn't know what to pronounce here
you know what though that's what
business can do
yeah business doesn't have to be greedy
and that
that's what business should be given
creating value helping the landlords
moving tenants in giving people jobs
yeah
you you are the prime example of why i
do what i do yeah and teach people and i
really appreciate that as well i think
again i'm gonna come back to this is
you you inspired me a lot right the
energy
and the way you portray stuff genuinely
you know itself is a motivation to me
right um it really helps me especially
when things go stuff
i said listen um someone makes
everything easy i know you're not going
to tell me he hasn't got stress he must
have
gone stressed but he tried to find a way
to get it done and over with so
that wakes me up in the morning to
actually get me to do what i'm doing
today
yeah and i think the reason i try and
make it easy is because i want people to
do it yeah of course
and and when we were just driving all
around cardiff literally i know you
don't like to brag and you don't like to
to your own horn
but it was like every other house was
either owned by you
or it was on a rent to rent by you or on
a lease option by you
yeah it's just like that was a lease
option that one's a rent around that
one's a rent event
and we went in several of the houses
yeah i mean just the last one can we
talk can we talk figures a little bit
just on the last time yeah we can talk
about it
so the last house yeah you've just
secured it on a rental rent
yeah talk me through the figures of the
house so
maybe secure the property for obviously
i had i had a v i had a
send a letter out to the landlord and
approach them that way
obviously template templates blueprint
everything some it's some of your
letters actually i used and i still use
them today it's good right they've got
them
but it's just standard anyone can do it
very straightforward you know like two
three lines she's done basically so the
magic words yeah the magic wands are
there so i sent it to them they
contacted me saying if i'm interested to
view i said yes i create an urgency in
it
and then i went to view the property
negotiated i was able to secure it for
1350 pounds
including bills so and this is just to
say
this is in like millionaires row yeah
this is in the
really nice part yeah it's in king koi
if i call the name is king quite
a king coin most of the houses are worth
a million plus in that area yeah so this
is a beautiful area
you agreed to pay 1 350 pounds
including the landlord paying all the
bills yes which is a bit of a steal
yeah it is so um i was able to secure
that at that price um
obviously i totally landed what i could
do to her property and
uh yes we hope we make we're gonna be
making about 520 to 580 per bedroom in
that
and how many bedrooms um it's five
bedrooms okay and have you
because you've only just took this rent
to rent on yeah have you already got
tenants that have
yes um three of the rooms have been
secured um tenant is moving on the first
one
on friday i'm getting we need to get
that done by then and
right now it's going under a little uh
decoration you're cleaning it
yeah so i'm telling you moving in on
friday
the other bedroom has been secured we've
got two two more viewings lined up for
thursday yeah and also with that
property you have marketed it and this
is what's great and i and i teach this
this is but you implement it and it's
exciting to see
is to market a property before it's
ready yeah so you don't wait until it's
all ready and all been cleaned you've
all been staged
you've already got three tenants moving
in one person's moving on friday
you're now under your backs against the
wall because you think i'm easily ready
but when you're under pressure that's
when you perform best exactly the
tenants are going to move in
so 30 and 50 you're paying to the
landlord you've got five tenants that
are moving in paying between five
twenty to five eight eighty yeah and
that's assuming no couples or anything
like that
no what kind of profit are you gonna be
making on that will you be making
minimum of about
eight hundred to one thousand pounds
profit yeah net profit
so net profit of eight to a thousand
pounds minimum including
assuming that there's no couples yeah
but also it doesn't take into account
you've arranged some pretty good things
with the landlady
yeah so talk to me about that so what i
want to intend to do is to buy the
property in the long run so i've hinted
the
um the landlady that i'd like to buy the
property she said okay if the properties
on the market wants her in-law
moved out and she's happy to sell it to
me so i'm looking to structure
a purchase list option on that property
so that
by the time my lease expires i may be
able to actually
buy it off her then so so that's that's
that's and have you done a lease option
before yeah i've done a few before from
your
from your course obviously so um which
has helped me a lot to secure lots of
deals yeah and i've seen
you've got a lease option agreement near
my house yeah yeah i do yeah which is
again how much profit is that going to
be making
that one would make me if i do it as a
renter i say we make an average of 1
500 pounds and you've got the option to
buy it an option to buy it and that's
again you just secured that what was it
about a month ago yeah about months ago
yes just about just over six months six
weeks ago so not only
were you financially free a couple years
ago one of these few
but you've gone on to do lots and lots
and lots of more deals
yeah and the thing is as well is that
property that we just talked about where
you're making about eight hundred two
thousand pounds
am i also writing thinking that you've
agreed half price rent until the end
until next year correct that which means
it's actually gonna be a lot more
yeah a lot more than that yeah so and uh
it's a surprising one to be honest and
because
i don't know monetary properties on
including bills i normally take
eight assets and then pay the bills so
in this one um yeah it's one of those
ones that
i was able to use the energy i got from
you actually get it because i went there
with excitement
yeah and unhappiness and try to
understand what the landlord position
was
and understand how i could help them
they genuinely knew that i was there to
help rather than just grab the property
for me i rather walk away from a deal
that i'm not going to add value to
yes so i was able to talk to them they
were asking for lots of money for it
walk the figures with them tell them
what they could get
if they were to take on that point on
that basis and what they could get
guaranteed with no problems
if they were to go on with the rent
guarantee scheme and
what i do basically is what you do i
really listen to one of your
video or one of the books you want by
by lawrence highway he said how you
structured the purchase lease option
deal yeah
you first said cash option and then
obviously then you throw in the purchase
lease option yeah
so i did kind of dissimilar but not with
that sort of strategy i said okay i
could manage this property for you
but you get this net profit yeah however
if i take it on a rental rent basis
you get this amount of money slightly
higher yeah right
it's kind of the same concept but in a
different sort of way of doing it so
i've used that
way so that's the reason why i was able
to actually get that property
and they realized that i was telling the
truth because they experienced landlords
themselves yeah exactly
you need to be ethical it needs to be
win-win yeah you need to tell people
what you want yeah
be direct yeah you have to um so the
training that you did with me then how
much did you pay for the property
investors crash course
good question i can't remember that that
was a pound yeah crap
yeah yeah that that was a pound yeah the
book that you got
was probably 10 pounds i got it for free
you know maybe you got it
but i think i've got it from the deal
finally extravaganza that was
about two and a half thousand i think so
yeah three thousand three thousand
around that price
was it worth the money absolutely you
know um
again um what i've learned is the best
investment you could make is on yourself
yeah right if you educate yourself you
could do a lot more you may not get the
roi instantly
but in the wrong run you would have
infinity
return on investment because you could
implement and replicate that strategy
over and over and over yeah
it's just about implementing what you've
learned what i've done was to implement
what you taught me
right and what i've learned from
different property coaches is to
implement when i learn something new i
implement it straight away yeah right
and i don't procrastinate
i used to but i don't procrastinate
anyway anymore i said the worst could do
is to lose what i've done
but you're not going to go worse but the
but the benefit i can get from that
is infinity yes so that's how i look at
it so
that has helped me a lot so i've
implemented it and i was able to secure
lots of deals
and based on those criteria that's how i
even got my state agency because i use
the same criteria some same requirements
learn from you
to get whatever properties i'm i'm i'm
getting now
and you and you've done training as well
with tony robbins yeah
absolutely amazing how much did you
recently invest in tony robbins wow lots
of money and uh roughly how much it's
about
12 and 15 k plus 15 000 yeah
[Music]
that would be for the train that i do
now i do train
people to do properties as well so which
i wanted
i had so many people approached me
previously from my windowsill
when it's wednesday but i never ever
considered doing it because i thought
i would not be able to add value to them
because when i'm trying to build my own
sort of portfolio
and uh i was like how how did i react
when you started doing that
yeah well i i was actually impressed i
thought you're going to say oh
why are you doing that i'm doing the
same thing when you're doing it but when
we went to that dinner you actually
encouraged
everybody to actually do whatever they
want you talked about writing books
if you want to do your training course
you can support them if they want to be
on the papers you can support them so
that also gives me an encouragement
actually you know what
he will not see me as a competitor yeah
so because
because i know your heart and we're of
a like of a light mind i know some i
sometimes get um
misjudged how how did you feel because i
know you had people reaching out to you
and said oh
when i went through my bad publicity
stage
everybody saw the videos and the news
stories
you know what what did you make of that
being someone that's been trained from
me from the beginning
and and you know right up until now like
what what did you make of all that and
when they called me
um the the short answer i gave to them
is don't believe what you see in the
media
right judge a guy by his behavior to you
not by someone else's perception right
everybody can see different angles of
the page of the all i know about is a
very good guy genuinely want to help
people
he's genuinely helped me and it's
impacted my life positively
so um the only way you would know
is working with that person don't just
assume based on someone else's opinion
so
someone in someone's else's opinion
should not be a fact if you want to find
out
go to his courses see if he adds value
to you especially when he's doing them
for free
you've got nothing to lose you go there
learn if you learn something
that means you've actually proved that
guy wrong
but don't go with someone else's
perception and as
most of them i was able to turn them
around and say listen um you may be
facing a similar thing when you become
bigger because there'll be people that
will be going against you straight
against you but it's nothing personal as
business
you go to his courses if it impacts your
life great if it doesn't if it's not for
you
move on but all i would say is impact my
life and he's helped me really really
well
especially with the energy his his
motivations and all the rest of things
he's got
has helped me actually move
quickly than i would have if i haven't
met you
where are you going to go from here then
on the property side are you planning on
taking over the whole of cardiff are you
going to be getting into development
what's that right
because i'm sure we'll meet again and do
an update of course absolutely
anytime right my plan is basically is to
get my
training business going i need a support
on that you got it um because i want to
give back
i know it was difficult for me to start
um especially when i did not have money
so i think the only way i could give
back is to help people
in that sort of situation to to actually
get the chance to do what i did so i do
this courses i do free courses and
obviously i've got my different course i
have
asked for little money for them to pay
just to provide the service that i pro
provide them on so i want to go full on
that so i can give back
and then i got my estate agency going so
i want that i want
the bar properties to be to go to
property estate agency in cardiff it's
getting there yeah
we are getting there we are going to get
there so i'm going to be going full on
marketing
you're going to be on billboards
shopping centers radio stations want to
go big
yeah i want to say when you think
properties think buy properties so
that's what the plan is on the estate
agency side of things so i've employed a
few people now i'm looking to work on
the business
rather than in the business and
obviously we're helping people along the
way with the training
and got few refurb going right now
and working with with with different
investors
as well as with my mentees with jv and
jv with my mentees as well
so i'm trying to develop that side of
refurbishment
project along the way and now i'm
looking for i've
had a plot of land obviously i sold that
um but i'm now
looking for another plot of land where i
may be able to buy build about 10 houses
on
yeah wow and then obviously hold on to
the assets and then obviously see if i
can pull all the investment back out and
move on
and what i've also started doing when
i'm looking for a management
manager on that is to do renovations
yeah because what i've learned was lots
of people approaching me now
wanting to do loft conversions
extensions and all the rest of it and
they know i've done it they've seen
what i'm doing with my property so they
want me to start doing that as well
so what i'm trying to do is basically is
to get a project manager to be managing
that for me
so any sort of renovation deals come
through they could go through that
great and the sourcing business is going
really really well right now we have
over
500 active investors that we work with
so again we are getting
deals from the state agents we negotiate
them
package them wrap them up up for our
investors
and my student so that we will be able
to help the landlord so desperately want
to sell
to be able to get their money as quickly
as possible so i'm really really looking
forward
to actually doing that and working with
you to help me grow all that sort of
thing
absolutely well i think what you do
brilliantly which is um
absolute perfect model is you're an
entrepreneur over here
which is rent to rents and all that sort
of deal packaging management
but then you take that money and then
you invest it yourself yeah so you're an
investor
and an entrepreneur yeah and and when
you roll those two walls together you
become wealthy so
it's been really good working with you
so far and to continue to in the future
and i really think you deserve every
success you've got and i couldn't
be happier for a better person to be to
be able to be successful so
respect and a lot of love guys i hope
you enjoyed that interview rahim is a
massive inspiration to me
i hope he's an inspiration to you too if
you want to watch his initial interview
that he did almost two years ago
you can check that out right here also
if you want to watch more winners
wednesday interviews and you want to be
inspired there's a whole playlist
right here every single week i interview
somebody but please don't forget to
subscribe down here and i look forward
to seeing you
next time